>> PREVIOUSLY ON..
AMERICAN'S NEXT TOP MODEL
>> WHOO!
>> MONIQUE WAS GONE,
BUT MELROSE STILL WASN'T
MAKING ANY FRIENDS.
>> ONE NIGHT, THAT I'M ASKING
THAT YOU GUYS JUST, LIKE,
TAKE IT DOWN A NOTCH.
>> BITCH.
>> A.J. EMBRACED HER DARK SIDE
IN A FREAKY PHOTO SHOOT...
>> THAT'S GREAT.
>> BUT MEGG...
>> I REALLY WANNA TAKE THIS OFF.
>> AND JAEDA
STRUGGLED TO STAND OUT.
>> (growls)
>> IN THE END,
MEGG WAS SENT HOME.
NINE GIRLS REMAIN.
WHO WILL BE ELIMINATED TONIGHT?
>> ♪ DO YOU WANT TO BE ON TOP? ♪
♪♪
>> ♪ I WANNA RUN FREE ♪
>> STANDING IN THE BOTTOM TWO,
IT'S KIND OF, LIKE,
DEPRESSING IN A WAY.
I WAS JUST LIKE,
"WOW, YOU KNOW...
(chuckles) I SUCK."
>> JAEDA, YOU'VE GOT THE GOODS,
BUT YOU'RE NOT BRINGING IT
TO THE TABLE.
>> BEING MY SECOND TIME
IN THE BOTTOM TWO,
I WAS JUST LIKE,
"WHAT THE HELL AM I DOING?"
>> SO, JAEDA,
YOU'RE GONNA GET ANOTHER CHANCE.
>> I WAS THE CLOSEST TO MEGG
OUT OF ANYONE IN THE HOUSE,
SO LOSING HER WAS LIKE
LOSING THIS HUGE SPIRIT.
>> BYE.
>> (faux sobbing)
I CRIED LIKE THAT WHEN
I THOUGHT I WAS GOING HOME,
BUT I'M NOT CRYING LIKE THAT
FOR ANYONE ELSE.
YOU GUYS CAN ALL GO HOME.
I'M FINE BEING HERE BY MYSELF.
>> I FEEL LIKE MICHELLE, LIKE,
SHE OPENS UP MORE.
>> YEAH, I DON'T.
>> I DON'T LIKE YOU ANY LESS.
>> OH, I KNOW.
I'M JUST JOKING WITH YOU.
>> I DO!
I THINK THE TWINS
ARE TWO DIFFERENT PEOPLE.
I MEAN, YOU THINK TWINS
ARE KIND OF ALIKE,
BUT I THINK AMANDA
IS JUST MORE SELF-CONSCIOUS
WITH HERSELF,
AND MICHELLE'S MORE OUTGOING.
>> ACTUALLY, YOU KNOW WHAT...
>> I LOVE YOU, TOO, EUGENA.
>> I HATE AMANDA!
>> (laughs)
OF COURSE, WHEN YOU'RE TWINS,
AND YOU'RE IN A COMPETITION,
THEY COMPARE US A LOT,
WHICH REALLY SUCKS.
>> I DON'T TELL PEOPLE
WHO I LIKE, SO IF THAT'S ANY...
>> HAVE YOU EVER HAD
A BOYFRIEND?
>> NO, NOT REALLY.
I THINK PRETTY MUCH ALL MY LIFE
I'VE BEEN HIDING THAT
I DON'T KNOW WHO I AM.
I'M STILL FINDING MYSELF,
AND, LIKE,
I'M FINALLY ABLE TO ADMIT,
LIKE, I HAVE NO IDEA.
I MIGHT BE... GAY.
I JUST DON'T KNOW
IF I AM OR NOT.
>> YEAH.
>> I DIDN'T KNOW IF MICHELLE
ACTUALLY CAME OUT OF THE CLOSET,
BUT I THINK
SHE'S STRADDLING THE FENCE.
>> YOU LOOK LIKE YOU'RE
A LITTLE MORE COMFORTABLE
IN YOURSELF.
>> YEAH, BEFORE I WAS KIND OF,
LIKE, SCARED OF IT,
BUT NOW IT'S LIKE, "WHATEVER."
>> WOW, TWINS.
>> YEAH.
THAT CAME OUT KIND OF RANDOMLY.
BUT I DIDN'T SAY I WAS GAY.
I SAID I DON'T KNOW IF I'M GAY,
'CAUSE I DON'T KNOW.
>> YEAH.
>> I DIDN'T REALLY WANNA
TALK ABOUT IT, AND I WAS
AVOIDING TALKING ABOUT IT
BECAUSE I DIDN'T WANNA
MAKE IT A BIG DEAL.
I WANTED IT TO, LIKE,
JUST GO AWAY.
>> I TOLD YOU BEFORE, RIGHT?
>> YEAH.
>> TYRA MAIL!
>> "I ONCE HEARD
THAT DUMB MODELS
ASK STUPID QUESTIONS.
I HAVE ALSO HEARD
THAT THERE'S NO SUCH THING
AS A STUPID QUESTION.
IS THERE? FIND OUT TODAY.
LOVE, TYRA."
>> HMM.
>> MAYBE WE'RE ACTING DUMB.
♪♪
>> HI!
>> MY NAME IS MARK STEINES.
I AM A COHOST
FOR "ENTERTAINMENT TONIGHT."
HI, EVERYBODY,
I'M MARK STEINES.
I HAD STARS, STARS
AND MORE STARS
ON THE RED CARPET.
>> YOU WORK IT OUT.
>> (laughs)
I'M IN MY 11th SEASON
ON THE SHOW, AND, UM,
HAVE TALKED TO VIRTUALLY
EVERY STAR IN HOLLYWOOD.
I'M HERE TO TEACH YOU GUYS
BASICALLY WHAT
A GOOD INTERVIEW IS.
YOU'LL GET A CHANCE
TO INTERVIEW ME,
AND I'LL TEACH YOU
SOME OF THE NUANCES
OF INTERVIEWING.
ASK A QUESTION, GET AN ANSWER.
IT SEEMS SIMPLE, BUT IT'S NOT.
ALL RIGHT, WANT TO PLAY?
>> YEAH!
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> SO YOU LOOK GREAT TONIGHT.
UH, WHAT ARE YOU WEARING?
>> WHO DO WE HAVE...
>> MARY-KATE AND ASHLEY--
OH, DOLCE & GABBANA,
VERY GOOD CHOICE.
>> MARY-KATE AND ASHLEY.
>> SO, MARK, HOW OLD ARE YOU?
>> I'M 42.
>> NO WAY.
>> I'LL BE 42.
>> THAT'S AWESOME.
>> YEAH.
>> THAT'S AWESOME. (laughs)
>> THERE YOU GO.
>> SO, MARK,
HOW DID YOU GET YOUR START
IN THE ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY?
WHERE DID YOU BEGIN?
>> WELL, YOUR QUESTIONS
ARE COMING IN LIKE
YOU'VE REHEARSED THEM
AND YOU STUDIED THEM.
BE YOURSELF.
>> ARE YOU MARRIED?
>> I AM.
MAN, THAT--
YOU ABOUT SNAPPED THE HEAD OFF OF THAT THING.
>> I'M SORRY. OKAY.
>> MARK!
>> HEY!
>> (laughs)
>> WHAT?
>> MARK, SO--
>> HUH?
>> I AM NOT GOOD AT, LIKE,
FINDING QUESTIONS TO ASK PEOPLE.
MARK... (laughs)
>> DO I HAVE TO CHANGE MY NAME?
IS IT THAT BAD?
>> OKAY, WAIT, NO, NO.
>> OKAY.
>> I GOTTA THINK. (laughs)
>> WELL...
>> DO YOU KNOW HOW TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS WITH, YOU KNOW,
THAT PERFECT LITTLE CHARM
SO YOU DON'T GET IN TROUBLE?
>> HOW AM I DOING?
>> YOU'RE ACTUALLY DOING
RATHER WELL.
>> AM I DOING WELL?
>> YEAH.
>> UM...
♪♪
>> I COULD TELL THAT
SHE WAS REALLY UNCOMFORTABLE.
SHE HAS SO NOT BEEN HER.
LIKE, SHE HASN'T BEEN, LIKE,
OUTGOING AT ALL.
>> WHAT'S YOUR SHOE SIZE?
(buzzer)
>> (snores)
>> MARK, HOW'S IT GOING?
>> IT'S REALLY WELL.
IT'S GOING WELL. I'M ENJOYING MYSELF.
>> UM...
I'M LOST. I'M SORRY.
>> DO YOU HAVE STAGE FRIGHT?
>> YES.
>> DO YOU FEEL BUTTERFLIES?
I BREAK OUT IN HIVES
WHEN I'M NERVOUS.
I DON'T LIKE JUST RUNNING UP
TO PEOPLE I DON'T KNOW
AND PROBING THEM
AND QUESTIONING THEM.
>> WE HAVE ONE LEFT--
MELROSE.
>> MEL-STANK.
>> WHAT IS UP WITH
THE "MEL-STANK" TODAY?
Y'ALL ARE JUST RUDE.
I DON'T CALL YOU GUYS
MEAN NAMES.
>> OKAY...
>> SMELL-ROSE.
>> LET'S PUT YOU IN THE HOT
SEAT.
COME ON DOWN.
>> (whispers) GET OUT OF MY WAY.
(normal voice) THE GIRLS
GIVE ME ATTITUDE,
BUT I DON'T REALLY CARE.
I'M GONNA FOCUS A LOT
ON KEEPING IT POSITIVE.
HI, MARK.
>> HI! HOW ARE YOU?
>> I'M MELROSE.
HOW ARE YOU DOING TONIGHT?
>> I'M--I'M GOOD.
YOU HAVE A LOT OF ENERGY.
>> YEAH! I'M HAPPY TO BE HERE.
>> GOOD.
>> IT'S GETTING TENSE
WITH THESE GIRLS.
I FEEL LIKE WHEN I'M LOOKING UP
AT ALL THE GIRLS LOOKING BACK
AT ME, THAT IT'S LIKE...
GRR, YOU KNOW?
THERE'S REALLY NO SUPPORT
SEEPING DOWN.
SO AT A YOUNG AGE,
DID YOU KNOW WHAT
YOU WANTED TO DO WITH YOUR LIFE?
>> I WANTED TO PLAY FOOTBALL.
>> YOU DID? THAT'S AWESOME.
>> YOU DID A REALLY GOOD JOB.
A LOT OF PERSONALITY
CAME WITH THAT... RIGHT?
>> SHE'S A DING-DONG.
>> RIGHT--RIGHT?
>> I'M GONNA DING-DONG YOU--YES.
YOU GIRLS ARE CRAZY.
LIKE, YOU GUYS CARE WAY TOO MUCH
ABOUT WHAT'S GOING ON WITH ME
THAN WHAT'S GOING ON
WITH YOURSELVES.
>> I HOPE TO SEE YOU SOMETIME
ON THE RED CARPET AND PUT
A MICROPHONE IN YOUR FACE...
>> YAY!
>> AND ASK YOU A QUESTION,
AND YOU GIVE ME A SOUND BITE.
>> THANK YOU!
>> OKAY, ALL RIGHTY. BYE.
♪♪
>> WHAT IS UP WITH YOU?
I-I HAD JUST COME OUT
THAT I MIGHT BE BISEXUAL
OR WHATEVER,
AND IT MADE ME FEEL REALLY GOOD.
BUT AMANDA'S UPSET, AND, LIKE,
I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT THE HECK'S HAPPENING
WITH MY SISTER.
YOU'RE NOT BEING
YOURSELF, STUPID!
>> I'M BEING MYSELF.
I WAS JUST MELLOW AND...
>> IT'S NOT YOU.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO SAY.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO TELL YOU.
>> DOES THE IDEA THAT
YOUR SISTER MIGHT BE GAY--
DOES THAT MAKE YOU
UNCOMFORTABLE?
>> I'M JUST--I FEEL BAD.
LIKE, I-I'M WORRIED ABOUT YOU,
THAT YOU'RE NOT BEING YOURSELF
AND YOU'RE, LIKE,
RESTRICTING YOU.
>> I'M BEING ME, I'M JUST...
I DON'T KNOW.
♪♪
>> TYRA MAIL!
>> "BEWARE OF SUPERMODEL.
SHE BITES!
LOVE, TYRA."
>> (roars)
>> I'M THINKING,
"ARE WE GOING OUT TO DINNER?"
YOU KNOW... BITES.
>> MY HAT.
♪♪
>> ♪ LADIES AND GENTLEMEN ♪
>> HI, LADIES.
>> HELLO.
>> WELCOME
TO GEOFF THOMAS DESIGNS.
MR. THOMAS IS UNVEILING
A LINE TONIGHT--
PART OF HIS CREATION.
YOU GUYS ARE PART OF IT.
IN FACT, I'M GOING TO ASK YOU
TO DO MY JOB
AND WORK THE RED CARPET.
>> AWESOME!
>> I WILL BE IN YOUR EAR
WITH AN EARPIECE.
I WILL HELP YOU ALONG.
YOUR INTERVIEW TONIGHT
IS GOING TO BE...
JANICE DICKINSON.
>> OH, MY GOD.
♪♪
>> AAH!
(laughs)
>> YOU HAVE NOT SEEN DIVA YET.
HEY, ZIP IT, BITCH. ZIP IT.
YOU'RE DEAD IN MY BOOK.
>> THAT'S GONNA BE
A HARD CHALLENGE.
>> I'VE SEEN HER
ALWAYS KIND OF BEING LIKE...
NOT A BITCH, BUT KIND OF LIKE--
YEAH, LIKE, KIND OF A BITCH.
♪♪
>> HI, CARIDEE. IT'S MARK.
KNOW YOUR QUESTIONS.
YOU'RE WORKING
FOR "E.T." TONIGHT, SWEETHEART.
MAKE US PROUD.
>> HI, JANICE!
UM, I JUST WANTED TO KNOW
WHAT MAKES JANICE DICKINSON
JANICE DICKINSON.
WHAT MAKES YOU SO, YOU KNOW,
OVER... I CAN'T THINK
OF THE WORD RIGHT NOW, BUT...
>> (grunts)
I'M--HONEY, I'M TRYING
TO HELP YOU WITH SIGN LANGUAGE.
>> WHAT MAKES YOU YOU?
WHAT MAKES YOU JANICE?
OVER... I--PUNGENT? I CAN'T--
>> "OVERPUNGENT"?
>> OOH, OOH, MMM.
>> "OVERPUNGENT" IS A SMELL.
IT'S A STRONG... SMELL.
>> JANICE,
YOU LOOK SEXY TONIGHT!
I'M BROOKE.
>> WARM HER UP FIRST, OKAY?
MAKE HER LIKE YOU.
>> SO TELL ME,
WHAT MAKES YOU SO BITCHY?
(needle scratches record)
>> NOT GOOD.
>> THANK YOU.
>> OH, MAN, I FEEL SORRY
FOR THE NEXT ONES COMING.
>> WHERE YOU FROM?
>> I'M FROM INDIA,
BUT ORIGINALLY...
BUT I'M FROM MIAMI--
MIAMI, FLORIDA.
>> SO WHAT MAKES YOU
SO ENERGETIC?
>> I LIKE THE FACT...
>> WHAT?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
IT'S A PIGEON... I DON'T KNOW.
>> WHAT IS...
>> I HEAR A LOT THAT, UM,
MODELS HAVE A LOT OF ATTITUDE.
SO DO YOU THINK THERE'S
ANY INAPPROPRIATE TIME
FOR A MODEL TO HAVE AN ATTITUDE?
>> I DON'T EVEN KNOW
HOW TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTION
'CAUSE YOU'RE MOVING SO MUCH.
>> I-I TRIED TO GET
THE SOUND BITES, BUT I THINK
MOST OF THE SOUND BITES
ARE OF HER MAKING FUN OF ME.
I HOPE YOU REALLY ENJOY
THE MARK THOMAS COLLECTION.
>> OH, MY GOD!
>> OR THE GEOFF THOMAS.
GEOFF THOMAS. SORRY.
AND THEN I MESSED UP
THE DESIGNER'S NAME,
WHICH IS PRETTY MUCH,
YOU KNOW...
KILL MYSELF.
(groans)
>> HI, I'M AMANDA.
>> JANICE DICKINSON.
>> NOW, JANICE, WHAT I KNOW
BOTH--BEST ABOUT YOU
IS THAT YOU'RE AMERICA'S
NUM--FIRST SUPERMODEL.
>> CAN YOU DEFINE
WHAT A SUPERMODEL IS?
CAN YOU TELL ME?
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> IF AMANDA WERE
A MODEL-CORRESPONDENT
AND CAME ONTO OUR SHOW,
I WOULD HAVE
TO LIGHT A FIRE UNDER HER.
>> WHAT'S THAT THING
ON YOUR HEAD?
>> IT'S--I DON'T EVEN KNOW.
>> THAT THING LOOKS LIKE
IT'S GOT MOTHBALLS IN IT.
>> OKAY, GET THE ATTENTION
OFF YOU, BACK ON TO HER.
GET TO THE QUESTIONS.
>> TAKE IT OFF.
CAN YOU DO ME THAT FAVOR?
>> YES, I CAN.
>> OH, NO, NO, NO.
YOU'VE LOST THE INTERVIEW.
GET THE MICROPHONE BACK.
>> CAN I HAVE
MY MICROPHONE BACK?
>> YES.
>> THANK YOU.
SO, UM... I'M FORGETTING
MY QUESTION RIGHT NOW.
>> DON'T EVER FORGET--INVENT.
MAKE THEM UP.
>> I'M TRYING.
I'M SCREWED AT THIS POINT,
SO I'M NOT EVEN GONNA PRETEND,
LIKE, TO TRY AND FIX IT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
>> ALL RIGHT. (chuckles)
>> TOODLES.
>> BYE.
>> SHE WAS BREAKING OUT
INTO HIVES.
OOH!
SHE'S ALL RED.
>> JANICE DICKINSON!
SO WHAT MADE YOU
THE ORIGINAL SUPERMODEL?
>> WELL, I COINED THE TERM
BACK IN 1979.
>> AND YOU'RE THE ORIGINAL
IDEAL BEAUTY FOR THIS--
>> BUT I COINED THE TERM!
>> YOU COINED THE TERM, GIRL!
AND ONE MORE QUESTION FOR YOU--
>> WAIT, WHAT IS THIS, A HICKEY,
OR DID SOMEBODY BRUISE YOU?
>> THIS IS--THAT'S A--
THAT'S A BIRTHMARK.
>> OH, IT'S A GOOD ONE.
>> SHE'S TURNING IT ON YOU.
GET IT BACK TO HER.
>> DO YOU HAVE ANY BIRTHMARKS?
>> UH, I DON'T.
>> VERY GOOD, VERY GOOD.
>> YES! SO, UM--
>> YOU DON'T REALLY KNOW...
>> (laughs)
>> YOU REALLY DON'T HAVE
THE HANDOFF YET.
IT'S JANICE IS TALKING,
NOW YOU TALK.
GIVE ME IT! GIVE ME THE MIKE!
>> (laughs)
>> SO, UM...
DAMN!
>> SO? SO? SO?
>> (laughs)
>> COME ON, ASK ME SOMETHING.
>> OKAY, SO, UM...
THERE'S A BLANK IN MY HEAD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I'M SORRY.
>> NOW GIVE ME THE MIKE! BYE!
WHOO-HOO!
(singsongy) HEY,
I'VE GOT THE MIKE!
>> (cheering)
>> QUESTION--
WHY IS THAT PINK THING
STILL ON YOUR HEAD?
DO YOU THINK THAT'S FASHION
AND ATTRACTIVE?
BECAUSE IT'S NOT.
I WOULDN'T WIPE YOUR CAR
WITH IT.
>> I LOVE MY HAT.
I DON'T CARE WHAT SHE THINKS.
>> THE WINNER OF THIS CHALLENGE
IS GOING TO JOIN
ME AND THE STAFF
AT "ENTERTAINMENT TONIGHT"
AND FILE A STORY FOR US.
>> WHOA!
>> THE PERSON THAT I WOULD LIKE
TO INVITE TO BE A CORRESPONDENT
IS...
MELROSE.
>> YAY! I AGREE!
>> YAY!
>> I AGREE! YOU DID SO WELL!
YOU KNOW WHAT?
GIRLS, I'M SORRY,
SHE BLEW Y'ALL AWAY.
>> A LOT OF THE GIRLS ARE LIKE,
"I WOULD NOT WANT TO WIN THAT."
I'M LIKE,
"YOU GUYS ARE TRIPPIN'."
(laughs)
THIS IS GONNA BE AWESOME!
♪♪
>> OH, MY GOD! IT'S TYRA.
>> OH, MY...
>> (laughter)
>> OH, MY GOD.
>> GO ON DOWNSTAIRS.
>> HI, TYRA!
>> I'M REALLY, REALLY EXCITED
TO SEE HER, AND I'M WONDERING
WHAT THE HECK'S GOING ON.
>> I HAVE DONE THIS CAREER
BACKWARDS AND FORWARD.
I KNOW THE INS AND OUTS
AND THE INSECURITIES
AND EVERYTHING,
AND IT'S IMPORTANT FOR ME
TO, HOPEFULLY,
OFFER YOU SOME GUIDANCE
AND SOME HELP.
ALL RIGHT, SO TODAY
WE'RE GONNA DO THAT, OKAY?
>> ALL RIGHT, COOL!
>> COOL!
>> WHAT IS THAT? WHO DREW THAT?
>> I DID THAT.
>> A.J., YOU DRAW WELL.
>> THANKS.
>> I'M REALLY HARD TO DRAW.
PEOPLE USUALLY MAKE ME
LOOK LIKE AN ALIEN...
>> (laughter)
>> SO THAT'S GOOD.
>> (chuckles)
>> SO HOW ARE YOU, A.J.?
>> I'VE BEEN BETTER.
>> WHAT DO YOU MEAN "BETTER"?
>> I FEEL LIKE
A LOT OF THE GIRLS HERE,
I CAN'T RELATE TO THEM,
SO I KINDA... KEEP TO MYSELF.
IT'S A LOT HARDER WHEN
YOU'RE STUCK IN A PLACE,
TRYING TO DO YOUR BEST
AND NOT BEING AROUND PEOPLE
THAT UNDERSTAND YOU, SO...
>> MM-HMM.
WHO'S TROUBLING YOU?
>> MELROSE.
SHE'S VERY--SHE'S ABRASIVE.
SHE'S NOT A NICE GIRL.
>> SO WHAT SHE PAINTS
IN THE JUDGING
IS NOT WHAT YOU ALL SEE?
>> YES.
>> 'CAUSE WE SEE A NICE,
SWEET BUBBLY PERSON.
>> YEAH. EXACTLY
>> HI, MELROSE.
>> HI, TYRA!
>> HOW ARE YOU?
HOW ARE YOU DOING?
>> I'M OKAY. (chuckles)
>> YOU--YOU'RE OKAY?
>> I'M NERVOUS. (laughs)
>> WHY ARE YOU NERVOUS?
>> MY HEART JUST BEATS WHENEVER
IT'S LIKE, "TYRA'S HERE!"
>> YEAH?
I'M LIKE... "DOO-DOO."
DO YOU THINK THE OTHER GIRLS
ARE INTIMIDATED BY YOU?
>> YEAH, I FEEL LIKE THEY JUST
DON'T WANT ME AROUND THEM.
IN A LOT OF MY LIFE,
JUST TRYING TO BE CONFIDENT--
AND MAYBE OVERLY
BEING CONFIDENT--MIGHT
PUSH PEOPLE AWAY AND MIGHT
BE LIKE, "UGH!" YOU KNOW?
>> I WANT YOU
TO CLOSE YOUR EYES,
REMOVE ALL OF THE ARMOR
AND THE PROTECTION.
>> OKAY.
>> ARE YOU SCARED
TO BE VULNERABLE?
>> YEAH, I'M SCARED...
BUT I'M STRONG.
>> MM-HMM.
SO HOW ARE YOU DOING, MISS EUGENA?
>> I'M FINE.
>> THAT SOUNDS LIKE
SUCH A LOADED "I'M FINE."
>> I'M--I'M JUST TRYING
TO WORK ON MY PICTURES,
THAT'S ALL.
I KNOW THAT'S THE
MOST IMPORTANT PART.
>> THE PICTURES
ARE A VERY IMPORTANT THING,
BUT I KNOW A LOT OF THE JUDGES
FEEL YOU GIVE OFF A COLDNESS.
>> HMM. IT'S JUST FRUSTRATING,
BECAUSE YOU SEE
ALL THE OTHER GIRLS THAT CAN
LET THEIR EMOTIONS OUT...
>> MM-HMM.
>> AND...
LIKE, I TRY TO,
BUT I KIND OF DON'T KNOW
HOW TO TAP IN TO THAT.
>> YOU'RE TAPPING RIGHT NOW.
>> (laughs)
>> THREE MONTHS AGO,
I HAD A SKIN DISEASE
THAT COVERED 78% OF MY BODY...
>> I DIDN'T KNOW THAT.
>> CALLED PSORIASIS.
YEAH, AND I ONLY HAVE, LIKE,
A LITTLE BIT LEFT
RIGHT IN THERE,
BUT, I MEAN, IT WAS, LIKE...
IT'S A REALLY EMOTIONAL THING,
'CAUSE I ALWAYS WANTED TO MODEL
AND I ALWAYS GOT TURNED DOWN.
MY WHOLE LIFE,
I JUST WANTED TO WAKE UP
AND PUT ON A PAIR OF SHORTS
AND WALK OUTSIDE, YOU KNOW,
IN FLIP-FLOPS--
SOMETHING THAT SO MANY PEOPLE
JUST TAKE FOR GRANTED.
>> SO HOW DOES IT FEEL
WHEN YOU'RE IN A PHOTO
AND YOU'RE ON TOP OF A CAR...
>> AND MY LEGS ARE SHOWING.
>> AND JUDGES ARE SAYING
IT'S BEAUTIFUL?
>> MY LEGS ARE IN THE SUN.
>> THE INTERESTING THING
IS I KNOW THAT
YOU'RE A PHOTOGRAPHER.
>> UH-HUH.
>> WERE YOU BEHIND THE CAMERA
BECAUSE YOU WERE SUFFERING WITH
THE PSORIASIS BUT DYING TO BE
ON THE OTHER SIDE?
>> YEAH, DEFINITELY.
DEFINITELY. YEAH.
>> HOW ARE YOU DOING, MISS MICHELLE?
>> I'M DOING GOOD.
>> YOU SEEM LIKE YOU'RE
FLOWERING, YOU'RE OPENING UP.
>> (chuckles) LIKE, FOREVER,
I TOTALLY THOUGHT, YOU KNOW,
YOU COULDN'T BE A MODEL
AND BE A TOMBOY AND BE GIRLIE.
YOU HAD TO BE, LIKE,
A GIRLIE-GIRL.
YOU KNOW, IT'S LIKE EVERYTHING
IS PUSHING ME TOWARDS IT.
I'M SO--I'M, LIKE, NATURALLY,
LIKE, GOOD AT IT KIND OF THING.
>> YOU ARE.
DO YOU EVER FEEL ANY GUILT THAT
YOUR SISTER WANTS IT MORE THAN
YOU DO, BUT YOU'RE DOING BETTER?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
I FEEL LIKE SHE JUST NEEDS
TO RELAX AND BE HERSELF.
LIKE, IT SEEMS LIKE
SHE'S TOTALLY NOT HERSELF HERE.
LIKE, SHE'S NOT TALKING
THAT MUCH, LIKE, NOT OUTGOING
LIKE NORMAL. IT'S LIKE,
I JUST WANT HER TO BE HER.
>> SO HOW ARE YOU DOING?
>> I DON'T KNOW. (laughs)
>> YOU DON'T KNOW?
I DO SEE, LIKE, SOMEBODY THAT'S,
LIKE, KIND OF WITHDRAWING
AND GOING INSIDE.
YOU DID HAVE, LIKE, A LIGHT.
WHY DO YOU THINK IT'S DIMMING?
>> I DON'T WANT, LIKE,
EVERYONE TO KNOW
EVERYTHING ABOUT ME,
AND THAT SCARES ME.
LIKE, MY SISTER KIND OF CAME OUT
THAT SHE DOESN'T KNOW
HER SEXUAL ORIENTATION.
I HAVEN'T REALLY
TALKED ABOUT IT MUCH, BUT I DON'T...
(sighs) GOD!
(chuckles)
>> IT'S OKAY.
>> WHEW.
I'M, LIKE...
I'M SCARED FOR MY SISTER,
'CAUSE IT'S LIKE,
"OH, NOW SHE'S A LESBIAN."
LIKE, MAYBE SHE'S NOT,
MAYBE SHE IS.
I DON'T CARE, BUT I DON'T KNOW
IF IT'S AMERICA'S RIGHT
TO KNOW, LIKE,
THAT ABOUT HER, YOU KNOW?
I DON'T KNOW.
I HAVEN'T CRIED--
OH, THIS IS WEIRD.
I DON'T CRY VERY OFTEN.
(chuckles)
>> I CRY ALL THE TIME.
>> (laughs)
>> I DO. I JUST CRIED YESTERDAY.
I CRIED YESTERDAY,
AND I CRIED FOR, LIKE,
TWO HOURS.
HAVE YOU TALKED TO HER ABOUT IT?
>> NOT REALLY,
'CAUSE I'VE BEEN TRYING
TO, LIKE, HIDE FROM...
>> THE CAT'S OUT THE BAG.
BUT IF SHE'S OPEN
TO TALK ABOUT IT...
>> I KNOW.
>> SHE NEEDS YOU
MORE THAN EVER NOW.
>> I KNOW.
>> MORE THAN EVER.
LIKE, YOU'RE HER ROCK.
(telephone dialing)
>> I TALKED TO TYRA
ABOUT MY SISTER BEING, UH...
I GUESS YOU COULD SAY
BISEXUAL,
AND IT'S--IT'S COOL NOW.
>> Hi.
>> HI, MOM.
MOST, LIKE, LESBIANS AND STUFF,
LIKE, THEY HAVE A HARD--
OR GAY PEOPLE HAVE A HARD TIME
COMING OUT TO THEIR PARENTS 'CAUSE THEY DON'T,
LIKE, UNDERSTAND.
THEY, LIKE, DISOWN THEM.
HOLD ON... I DON'T KNOW
HOW TO SAY THIS.
UM...
I ANNOUNCED THAT I DON'T KNOW
IF I'M STRAIGHT OR NOT.
>> Okay.
>> You doing okay?
>> (mouths words)
>> HELLO?
>> Hi.
>> WHAT'D YOU SAY?
>> I didn't say anything.
>> OH.
>> Is it Michelle or Amanda?
>> AMANDA.
>> Where is she?
>> SHE'S UPSET.
>> Let me talk to her.
>> OKAY, MOMMY WANTS
TO TALK TO YOU.
>> (laughs)
>> MICHELLE IS A STRONG PERSON.
I WAS JUST HAPPY TO BE THERE.
I DON'T CARE WHAT TYPE
OF SEXUALITY SHE IS.
SHE'S MY SISTER.
>> I love you.
>> I LOVE YOU, TOO.
>> You doing okay?
>> MM-HMM.
>> Don't fret about this,
sweetie.
We love you no matter what.
>> I KNOW.
>> Okay?
>> I LOVE YOU, MOMMY.
>> I love you, too, sweetie.
>> HAPPY MOTHER'S DAY.
>> I'M GOING ON AN ASSIGNMENT
WITH "ENTERTAINMENT TONIGHT,"
AND I'M GONNA
BE INTERVIEWING PEOPLE.
I'M KIND OF NERVOUS.
IT'S A LOT OF PEOPLE.
IT'S A LOT OF LIGHTS.
I'M LIKE, "OKAY, JUST BREATHE."
>> THE WINNER!
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU DON'T LOOK NERVOUS AT ALL.
>> I'M NOT NERVOUS.
>> THAT'S WHY
YOU WON THE CHALLENGE.
>> I HEAR YOU LIKE TO DANCE.
>> A LITTLE BIT. YOU?
>> I LOVE IT.
OH, OH, OH!
>> RIDE IT BACK.
>> LET'S SEE YOUR BEST WALK
FOR THE "AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL" VIEWERS.
>> I'M EMBARRASSED. I'LL JUST--
I'LL JUST GIVE YOU A POSE.
>> OOH, HOO, SEXY!
>> DON'T COPY THAT.
>> VERY SEXY.
GOOD TO SEE YOU!
>> YOU, TOO!
>> WHAT IS THE MOST UNCOMFORTABLE THING
THAT YOU ARE WEARING TONIGHT?
>> PROBABLY BE MY SHOES. UM...
>> SHOES? SHOULD WE TAKE
OUR SHOES OFF FOR A SECOND?
>> YEAH, LET'S TAKE 'EM OFF.
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> YEAH.
>> I'M TAKING 'EM OFF.
OOH, THAT FEELS GOOD.
>> YOU'RE DOING SO GOOD!
>> THANKS, TYRA!
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
>> I THINK IT'S A GREAT PRIZE.
I'M HAPPY I WON IT.
>> TYRA MAIL!
"TOMORROW,
YOU'LL WORK WITH THE PERSON
WHO KNOWS YOU BEST.
LOVE, TYRA."
>> OOH!
>> THAT'S WEIRD.
>> (gasps) FAMILY?!
AAH!
>> TYRA!
♪♪
>> HEY, SEXY.
>> HEY.
>> HEY, GOOD MORNING.
>> GOOD MORNING.
>> ARE YOU GUYS READY
FOR SOME ENERGY?
>> YES!
>> BECAUSE TODAY,
YOU GIRLS ARE GOING TO POSE
WITH YOURSELVES
IN A PHOTOGRAPH.
WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO
IS SHOOT YOU ONCE,
AND SEND YOU BACK
TO HAIR AND MAKEUP
AND THEN SHOOT YOU AGAIN.
TODAY, YOU GIRLS ARE GOING TO BE
CELEBRITY COUPLES.
>> (laughter)
>> AH!
>> NO WAY!
>> CARIDEE,
WE THOUGHT YOU'D BE A GOOD
BRAD AND ANGELINA.
>> OH, THAT'S HOT!
>> BROOKE?
>> YES?
>> BRITNEY AND KEVIN.
EUGENA, YOU'RE GONNA BE
BEYONCé AND JAY-Z.
A.J., YOU'RE GONNA BE
J.LO AND MARC ANTHONY.
>> OH, MY GOD!
>> MICHELLE, YOU'RE GONNA BE
ELLEN DeGENERES...
>> (laughs) OKAY.
>> AND PORTIA de ROSSI.
>> THAT'S GOOD.
>> AMANDA,
DEMI AND ASHTON.
>> I KNEW IT!
>> JAEDA,
BOBBY AND WHITNEY HOUSTON.
>> OH, MY GOD!
>> ANCHAL, YOU'RE GONNA BE
OPRAH AND STEDMAN.
>> OH!
>> MELROSE,
YOU ARE GONNA BE
DONALD TRUMP AND MELANIA.
>> (laughter) DONALD TRUMP!
>> WHY ARE YOU--YOU'RE--
YOU GUYS ARE TORTURING ME.
>> WE'RE NOT TORTURING YOU.
>> AND I GET
THE DONALD TRUMP ONE--
I'M LIKE, "COME ON!
LIKE, HE'S THE OLDEST GUY
OUT OF ALL THESE PEOPLE."
AAH!
>> TO SHOOT YOU AS CELEBRITIES,
WE HAD TO GET A PHOTOGRAPHER
WHO HAS MADE HIS CAREER
IN SHOOTING CELEBRITIES.
♪♪
>> YOU'RE GONNA WORK
HARDER TODAY
THAN YOU'VE EVER WORKED
IN YOUR LIFE.
I WANT YOU TO BE ON
THE ENTIRE TIME.
♪♪
>> ♪ YEAH ♪
>> I'M DOING JAY-Z FIRST,
SO THEY'RE TRYING
TO MAKE MY EYEBROWS
AS BUSHY AS POSSIBLE
AND WIDEN MY NOSE.
>> THIS WHOLE THING'S
ALL ABOUT HAVING FUN.
>> AND BEYONCé'S
GONNA BE RIGHT HERE?
>> YEP.
>> YOU KNOW,
YOU RAPPIN', YOU VIBIN'.
♪ YEAH, YEAH ♪
♪ UNH ♪
♪ DANCE AND GO, "YO" ♪
>> BUT I NEED TO SEE YOUR FACE.
>> WHAT'S UP?
>> PERFECT.
>> ALL RIGHT!
SO WHEN YOU COME DOWN
AS BEYONCé,
I'M GONNA NEED DIVA.
>> GIVE ME A GREAT FACE, ALSO...
THAT LITTLE SPARKLE
RIGHT THERE IN THE EYE.
>> YOU'RE DOING THIS...
AND I WANT... AHH!
THAT'S BETTER. THAT'S BETTER.
>> THERE WE ARE.
>> I JUST NEED
A LITTLE "UNH! UNH!"
A LITTLE SOMETHING-SOMETHING.
THERE YOU GO.
>> IT'S OKAY.
>> (whines)
LOOK, I GOT JAEDA'S HAIR.
>> THAT'S NOT MY HAIR!
>> YOU KNOW, THINK OF IT--
STEDMAN IS A TALL, REGAL MAN.
>> IT IS WAY HARDER
TO PLAY A MALE.
I DON'T KNOW HOW THEY WALK.
I DON'T KNOW HOW THEY TALK.
>> THAT'S NICE. PERFECT.
>> NOW YOU HAVE TO COME DOWN
AS OPRAH WINFREY.
>> I'M OPRAH.
>> I LOVE THE SMILE. IT'S GREAT.
OPRAH'S ALL ABOUT
HAVING THIS INNER CONFIDENCE
GIVE ME ONE OF THESE AGAIN.
LIKE, "YEAH!"
YOU KNOW WHAT?
I DIDN'T THINK
YOU WERE GONNA DO IT.
>> I FINALLY GOT IT!
THANK YOU!
>> OH, MY GOD!
LOOK AT BRAD!
>> (deep voice) I GOT SOME KIDS NOW.
>> (crying)
>> OH, BABY.
IF I WAS A KID AND I WAS LOOKING
AT SOMEONE LIKE ME
WITH A WOMAN'S VOICE
AND THIS KIND OF LOOK,
I'D BE SCREAMING FOR HELP, TOO.
>> (crying)
>> AGAIN. THAT'S NICE.
>> (normal voice) KID,
JUST BE GOOD. COME ON, AND,
LIKE, IF YOU ONLY UNDERSTOOD
THAT THIS IS A COMPETITION...
>> (crying)
>> IT'S OKAY, BABY.
>> LET'S GO, LET'S GO,
LET'S GO, CARIDEE.
>> READY?
>> GOOD.
>> GOOD JOB, CARIDEE.
>> GREAT JOB.
>> OOH, IT WAS TOUGH, MAN.
♪♪
>> THAT'S NICE.
>> THAT LITTLE ADORING GLANCE
BACK AT BRAD...
I LOVE WHEN YOU PULLED
YOUR HAIR BACK A LITTLE
WHEN IT WAS--YES.
>> LOVELY. BEAUTIFUL.
>> OH, MY GOD, THAT WAS SO GOOD!
>> BEAUTIFUL!
>> THANK YOU!
VERY SEXY.
>> I'M JEALOUS OF CARI
'CAUSE SHE HAD
ANGELINA AND BRAD.
I WANTED THAT.
>> LET'S GO.
>> OH, MY GOD.
(groans)
>> I THINK YOU'RE
A LITTLE SCARED OF THE SHOT.
BE IN THAT MOMENT,
AS OPPOSED TO GOING...
>> (laughs)
>> I'M KIND OF SURPRISED.
A.J. ISN'T REALLY BEING
AS CREATIVE
AS I WOULD LIKE HER TO BE.
I'M A LITTLE NERVOUS ABOUT
WHEN SHE COMES BACK AS J.LO.
>> GROW.
>> OW!
(laughter)
>> COME ON, A.J.
PUT THAT HAND ON THAT HIP.
>> ACCENT THOSE ASSETS.
>> ASS-ETS.
>> J.LO WAS SO ECSTATIC
AT HER WEDDING.
>> IT'S HER WEDDING DAY.
>> (groans) THAT'S AS FAR
AS MY FACE GOES.
WELL, I'M GIVING WHAT I CAN
TO THE SITUATION,
AND IF I CAN'T GIVE ENOUGH,
THEN THAT'S MY PROBLEM.
MMM.
♪♪
>> THERE YOU GO.
JUST CHILL INTO IT A BIT MORE.
>> I JUST WANTED TO LOOSEN UP
AND JUST HAVE FUN WITH IT.
>> THERE, THERE!
>> I DIDN'T WANNA BE
TOO PERFECT.
>> HAM IT UP FOR ME.
THANK YOU.
>> ALL RIGHT,
SEE YOU IN A LITTLE BIT.
>> SEE YOU IN A BIT.
♪♪
>> NO WAY!
IS THAT A SNAKE?
MY PROP AS BRITNEY IS A SNAKE.
(gasps)
AN 8-FOOT HUGE YELLOW PYTHON
NAMED BANANA.
THAT'S SO COOL.
>> HERE YOU GO.
>> (screams)
OH, MY GOD, IT'S AROUND MY LEG!
>> YEAH, SHE'S VERY FRIENDLY.
>> IT'S RAPING ME!
>> BE GOOD.
>> THAT'S NICE, BROOKE.
>> GENIUS.
THERE YOU GO, BROOKE.
>> BEAUTIFUL. THAT'S IT.
>> BROOKE PROVED TO ME
THAT SHE HAS A LITTLE SOMETHING
BREWING UNDERNEATH
THAT "PERFECT" VENEER.
>> THERE WE ARE. THERE WE ARE.
NICE. THAT'S NICE.
THAT'S A WRAP.
>> GOOD JOB.
>> GOOD-BYE, LITTLE BANANA.
>> GOOD STUFF. WELL DONE.
>> YOU ARE BOBBY BROWN.
>> I FEEL LIKE BOBBY BROWN.
>> THERE WE ARE.
>> YEAH!
UNH!
>> I FELT REALLY COMFORTABLE
BEING BOBBY BROWN.
I WAS JUST SO SURPRISED
THAT, YOU KNOW,
I WAS ABLE TO GO OUT
AND HAVE THAT ENERGY.
>> NOW CAN YOU COME DOWN
AS WHITNEY AND NAIL IT?
>> I'M JUST READY
TO BE AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,
AND I'M GONNA DO ANYTHING
TO GET IT.
>> I'D GO SLIGHTLY DARKER.
>> WELL, NOW YOU HAVE HAIR.
>> YEAH. OH, YEAH.
(mouthing words)
>> OOH! YEAH!
YES! THANK YOU!
JAEDA AS WHITNEY?
I DON'T KNOW IF I BELIEVE IT 100%,
BUT I AM GONNA GIVE JAEDA
"A" FOR EFFORT.
>> THANK YOU, JAEDA.
>> OH, MY.
>> OH, MY GOD.
YOU LIKE HER HAIRCUT ON YOU?
>> I LIKE IT ON HER.
I DON'T--I DON'T LIKE IT
SO MUCH ON ME.
>> I THOUGHT IT WAS
KIND OF IRONIC THAT MY SISTER'S
THE LESBIAN COUPLE.
>> HEY, GUYS.
>> THERE WE ARE. COME ON!
>> WHAT'S UP?
>> RIGHT NOW IT'S LOOKING
A LITTLE DORKY,
AND I KNOW YOU CAN MOVE.
TAKE TWO SECONDS
AND GIVE ME AN ELLEN DANCE
REAL QUICK.
THERE YOU GO! THERE YOU GO!
LOVE IT!
>> THERE WE ARE! THAT'S BETTER.
>> (laughter)
>> ALL RIGHT, GO TURN
INTO PORTIA de ROSSI FOR ME.
>> OKAY.
>> (laughter)
>> A.J.,
THIS DRESS IS WORTH $15,000!
>> WOW!
>> I'M NOT USED TO BEING
REALLY GLAMOROUS AND ELEGANT.
>> YOU DON'T LIKE
BEING THE "FEMININE" TWIN.
>> (laughs)
>> WELL, YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO LEARN HOW TO BE.
MAKE IT WORK.
>> ALL IN THE FACE, DEAR.
ALL IN THE FACE.
THAT'S BETTER.
>> THAT'S PRETTY.
>> MY TRANSFORMATION TO DEMI
WAS REALLY GOOD,
BUT REALLY, REALLY,
CAN I JUST WEAR A DRESS
OR SOMETHING?
>> BEAUTIFUL THERE.
THAT'S NICE.
THERE WE ARE.
KEEP GOING.
♪♪
>> ASHTON KUTCHER IS...
>> IS OVER-THE-TOP.
>> HE'S OVER-THE-TOP.
HE'S CRAZY.
LIKE, "DUDE!"
>> THAT'S NICE, AMANDA.
>> DO THE "SHH" AGAIN.
THAT'S GOOD.
YOU KNOW, I WAS SURPRISED.
SHE WAS SO INTO IT.
SHE REALLY STEPPED UP
HER ENERGY,
AND I COULDN'T HAVE
EXPECTED MORE OUT OF AMANDA TODAY.
>> THINK YOU DID GOOD?
>> YEAH, IT WAS FUN.
>> DID THEY SAY YOU DID GOOD?
>> YEAH.
>> ARE WE GOING
TO YOUR RESTAURANT TONIGHT?
>> I THINK I DID GOOD.
I THINK I DID REALLY GOOD,
AND MICHELLE DID REALLY WELL
AT HER PHOTO SHOOT,
SO THE TWINS ARE HERE TO STAY.
>> OH, MY GOD,
THIS LOOKS LIKE HER.
I FEEL LIKE I'M DOING WELL
IN THIS COMPETITION,
BUT I FEEL VERY ALONE,
'CAUSE IT SEEMS LIKE
THESE GIRLS ARE INTIMIDATED
OF ME OR SOMETHING.
>> FAN.
A LITTLE BIT.
>> OH, I LOVE WHAT
SHE'S DOING NOW.
THIS IS ALMOST LIKE
"TOP MODEL" HISTORY.
ALMOST EVERY FRAME IS USABLE,
SO YOU MAKE ME SICK
SO JUST LEAVE.
>> (laughs) I LOVE YOU, JAY!
I DON'T THINK ANY OTHER GIRL
GOT THE COMPLIMENT
THAT JAY GAVE ME
ABOUT "TOP MODEL" HISTORY,
BUT I'M NOT GONNA
GO AND TELL THEM THAT.
>> HOW YOU DO, GIRL?
>> I THINK I DID GOOD.
♪♪
>> DONALD TRUMP.
NICE TO MEET YOU.
HELLO, EVERYBODY.
LET'S GET TO WORK.
>> THIS IS DONALD TRUMP, YO.
>> BUT HONESTLY,
WE ALREADY GOT OUR SHOT.
REMEMBER NOW,
MELANIA IS GONNA BE
ON YOUR LEFT.
>> I PAID FOR HER...
>> (laughter)
>> EVERY PART OF HER BODY.
>> THAT WAS GOOD. THAT WAS GOOD.
>> OKAY.
(imitating Donald Trump) MELROSE
WILL BE AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,
ALL OF YOU,
OR ELSE YOU'RE FIRED.
(laughs)
♪♪
>> TYRA MAIL! "TOMORROW,
YOU WILL MEET WITH THE JUDGES.
ONLY EIGHT WILL CONTINUE ON
IN HOPES OF BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
LOVE, TYRA."
>> ♪ SOMEBODY'S GOING HOME ♪
♪ AND IT AIN'T GONNA BE ME ♪
>> ♪ TOMORROW ♪
♪ YOU WILL MEET ♪
♪ WITH THE JUDGES ♪
>> I FEEL LIKE I DID
REALLY GOOD IN MY PHOTO SHOOT,
BUT I'M BAD AT INTERVIEWING,
SO I'M REALLY NERVOUS
ABOUT PANEL.
>> (laughs)
>> WELL, I DON'T THINK
THEY'RE GONNA SEND ANYBODY HOME
BY, LIKE, HOW MUCH THEY
LOOK LIKE THEM, BUT HOW MUCH YOU
REALLY GOT INTO THE CHARACTER
AND TRIED TO BE THEM.
>> YEAH, YEAH.
>> IF I AM IN THE BOTTOM TWO
OF THIS ELIMINATION AGAIN,
THAT'S THE THIRD TIME.
I REALLY DON'T KNOW
WHAT I WOULD DO.
♪♪
>> WELCOME TO THE JUDGING ROOM,
LADIES.
YOU'VE HAD A WHIRLWIND
OF A WEEK, HAVEN'T YOU?
>> YES.
>> A LOT OF TALKING
AND A LOT OF OVER-THE-TOP,
OUTRAGEOUS MODELING.
YOU KNOW ABOUT
OUR FABULOUS PRIZES,
AND THE FIRST PRIZE
IS A MODELING CONTRACT
WITH ONE OF THE TOP
MODELING AGENCIES IN THE WORLD--
ELITE MODEL MANAGEMENT...
A COVER AND A 6-PAGE
EDITORIAL SPREAD
IN "SEVENTEEN" MAGAZINE...
AND A $100,000 CONTRACT
WITH COVERGIRL COSMETICS.
YOU GUYS KNOW THE JUDGES.
THE FIRST IS THE NOTED
FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER
NIGEL BARKER...
FASHION DIVA
RUNWAY COACH EXTRAORDINAIRE
MISS J. ALEXANDER...
>> MMM, MMM.
>> FASHION ICON
AND LIVING LEGEND MISS TWIGGY...
>> GOOD AFTERNOON.
>> AND A MAN THAT
I KNOW VERY WELL
AND LOVE VERY MUCH,
TOP FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER
MATTHEW JORDAN SMITH.
SO NOW IT'S TIME
FOR YOUR JUDGING TEST.
A LOT OF THE WINNERS
FROM "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"
HAVE DONE A LOT
OF LIVE COMMENTARY.
>> RIGHT NOW I'M BACKSTAGE
AND ALL AROUND
OLYMPUS FASHION WEEK,
COVERING FOR STYLE NETWORK.
>> WE ARE HERE
AT THE MAL SIRRAH FASHION SHOW.
>> SO THIS IS
A VERY IMPORTANT PART
OF THIS COMPETITION,
AND TODAY WE'RE GONNA
TEST YOU ON THAT,
AND, ANCHAL, YOU'RE FIRST.
SO WE'RE GONNA BE DOING
A LITTLE ROLE-PLAYING TODAY.
YOU'RE GONNA BE
PROVIDING COMMENTARY FROM
AN "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"
FINALE PARTY,
AND IT IS UP TO YOU
TO GIVE YOUR P.O.V.
>> WHAT'S A P.O.V.?
>> YOU SERIOUS?
>> I JUST--PLEASE LET ME KNOW.
>> POINT OF VIEW.
>> HI, EVERYBODY,
THIS IS MELROSE
WITH ANTM FASHION TELEVISION.
>> OH, IT'S TYRA.
SHE'S POSING, DOING THE TYRA.
PROBABLY A WEAVE,
BUT I'M NOT QUITE SURE.
>> I'VE GOT IT...
I HAD IT UPSIDE-DOWN. PFFT.
>> (laughs)
>> OH, MISS J.'s LOOKING
MIGHTY NICE, AND MR. JAY,
IN THEIR BLACK EYELINER,
LOOKING LIKE THEY JUST GOT BACK
FROM A FUNERAL OR SOMETHING.
>> SMILE FOR US.
YOU'RE LOOKING A LITTLE BIT
TOO SERIOUS, MISS J.
>> $40,000 PIN
ON MR. JAY HERE TONIGHT.
>> J.'s LOOKING LOVELY
IN HIS DRESS...
GOWN.
>> WHAT'S HE GOT
UNDER THAT DRESS?
OH, GOODNESS,
HE'S GONNA SHOW US!
>> LADIES AND GENTLEMEN,
TAKE NOTES,
BECAUSE THIS IS WHAT
THE PROFESSIONALS DO.
>> MISS J. IS SWOOPING AROUND
IN A BIG TRASH BAG.
>> JAY--THE JAYS, UM...
GOD!
WOW, THEY LOOK AMAZING.
>> UM...
I HAVE NO IDEA
WHAT'S GOING ON.
>> MR. JAY'S IN A NICE SUIT.
GOD, I'M SO NERVOUS.
(whispers) I'M SO NERVOUS.
>> I'M HUNGRY.
>> I'M HUNGRY, TOO.
>> I'M GOING TO THE KITCHEN.
ANYBODY WANT ANYTHING?
>> OKAY.
>> ALL RIGHT, COME ON, CARIDEE.
YOU'RE FIRST.
>> CARIDEE,
YOU HAD GOOD COMMENTARY.
>> WELL DONE.
I THINK YOU DID BRILLIANTLY.
>> PHEW!
>> ALL THE GIRLS
HAD A PHOTO SHOOT THIS WEEK
WHERE THEY HAD TO EMBODY
FAMOUS COUPLES.
WHAT COUPLE WERE YOU EMBODYING?
>> BRAD PITT AND ANGELINA JOLIE.
>> WHOO!
>> WOW.
>> THAT LOOKS LIKE HER!
>> VERY GOOD.
>> SEXY, BEAUTIFUL
AND VERY ANGELINA.
>> FOR SUCH
A PRETTY, PRETTY GIRL,
I THINK THAT'S AMAZING.
>> THANK YOU.
>> WELL DONE.
>> ALL RIGHT, UP NEXT IS JAEDA.
SO, JAEDA, YOU SEEMED UPSET
AT THE CHALLENGE,
SO YOU JUST WERE LIKE,
"I'M NOT GONNA REALLY DO THIS."
>> GOD! I'M...
>> YOU DON'T SHOW
YOUR ENTIRE AUDIENCE...
"I'M--I'M TERRIBLE."
>> ALL RIGHT,
SO, JAEDA, YOU WERE...
>> BOBBY AND WHITNEY.
>> OH.
>> HELL TO THE NO!
>> (laughter)
>> I CAN'T EVEN LOOK AT THAT!
OH, MY GOD!
>> WHEN I SAW YOUR BOBBY FILM,
I WAS SO PROUD OF YOU.
I DIDN'T THINK THAT
YOU HAD THIS IN YOU.
YOU JUST COMMITTED 100% PERCENT.
>> IN THE BOBBY ONE,
THE EYES I BELIEVE,
AND IN THE WHITNEY HOUSTON SHOT,
THE EYES LOOK A LITTLE WORRIED.
>> GOTTA GET OVER YOUR FEAR,
MY DEAR.
>> OKAY, UP NEXT IS BROOKE.
>> SO YOU HAD A CHALLENGE
WHERE YOU WERE
A FASHION CORRESPONDENT.
ALL I CAN SAY IS, "WOW!"
>> GOOD!
>> GIRLS, LOOK AND LEARN.
>> JUST DON'T HOLD
THE MICROPHONE UPSIDE-DOWN.
>> YEAH.
>> (laughs)
>> I WAS BRITNEY SPEARS
AND K-FED.
>> WHOO!
>> YOU ARE WORKING THAT SNAKE,
AND THAT'S A REAL SNAKE.
>> SHE CAME OUT,
AND SHE WAS KEVIN,
SHE WAS BRITNEY.
YOU NAILED IT.
>> YOU HAD THAT HOMEBOY THING
GOING ON WITH KEVIN, LIKE,
"WHAT, BRITNEY? YO, HUH.
YEAH, YOU KNOW I LOVE YOU."
>> I CAN RAP, TOO. REMEMBER?
>> I KNOW.
WHY DON'T YOU
RAP ABOUT THE PICTURE?
>> ♪ MY PICTURE'S LOOKING GOOD ♪
♪ MY PICTURE'S LOOKING FLY ♪
♪ I TOOK IT TO THE NEXT LEVEL ♪
♪ I GOT HIGH ♪
♪ BOYS, CHECK IT OUT ♪
♪ I'M REVVING IT FULL THROTTLE ♪
♪ I'M STANDING HERE ♪
♪ I'M GONNA BE ♪
♪ AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL ♪
>> OH!
>> (laughs)
>> AMANDA.
>> MY MAIN PROBLEM WITH YOU
IS YOUR VOICE...
(lowers voice) IS SO WEAK
AND SO QUIET.
>> J.'s LOOKING LOVELY
IN HIS DRESS.
>> YOU'RE SCARED AND TIMID. ALL RIGHT,
SO, AMANDA, YOU WERE...
>> ASHTON AND DEMI MOORE.
>> TO ME, THIS IS THE MOST
CONVINCING SHOT SO FAR.
>> I AGREE.
>> YOU HAVE THAT SULTRY,
LIKE, RELAXED ENERGY
THAT I THINK DEMI MOORE HAS.
>> AMANDA, THIS SHOWS THAT
YOU CAN BE A TRUE COMEDIAN,
WHICH IS WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING FOR IN A MODEL.
I MEAN, THIS IS REALLY GOOD.
>> SO, EUGENA,
THERE'S CERTAIN THINGS
THAT YOU SAID THAT I THOUGHT
WERE KIND OF BITING,
KIND OF JOAN RIVERS.
SHE SAID THAT MISS J.'s DRESS
LOOKED LIKE A TRASH BAG.
BUT IT'S THE KIND OF STUFF
THAT PEOPLE SITTING ON THE COUCH
WANT TO HEAR.
ALL RIGHT, EUGENA,
SO YOU WERE...
>> I WAS JAY-Z AND BEYONCé.
>> UH-OH.
>> MM-HMM.
>> WHOO!
>> OOH!
>> (laughs)
>> IS JAY-Z A POP SINGER?
>> HE'S A RAPPER, TWIGGY.
>> (laughter)
>> I'M SORRY.
LISTEN, IT'S NOT
MY AGE GROUP, DEAR.
>> YOU LOOK LIKE BEYONCé,
BUT I THINK YOUR EYES...
>> DEAD.
>> COULD STILL HAVE MORE LIFE.
>> YOU KNOW BEYONCé IS ALWAYS...
(imitates Beyoncé singing)
SHE DOESN'T GO LIKE THIS...
♪ UH UH UH UH OH ♪
ALL RIGHT,
LET'S SEE A CLOSE-UP OF JIGGA.
I LIKE THAT.
>> THIS, QUITE FRANKLY,
IS ONE OF YOUR BETTER SHOTS,
AND PARTLY BECAUSE YOU--
I DON'T SEE YOUR EYES.
>> SO, A.J., YOU HAD TO DO
FASHION COMMENTARY.
I WAS LOOKING AT YOU
AND THINKING, "THIS IS
BAD PUBLIC ACCESS TELEVISION."
>> I HAVE NO IDEA
WHAT'S GOING ON.
>> IT WAS PRETTY AWFUL.
I'M SURE YOU WOULD AGREE.
>> (blows a raspberry)
I WAS J.LO AND MARC ANTHONY.
>> THE BOOTY'S NICE.
>> YES!
>> WHAT I WAS GONNA SAY.
>> IT LOOKS A LITTLE CHEESY.
I DON'T BELIEVE IT.
YOU HAVE SUCH A--
A STRONG CHARACTER OF YOUR OWN,
AND I FEEL THAT YOU'RE SCARED
THAT YOU'RE GONNA LOSE IT
OR SOMETHING.
>> MARC ANTHONY IS IN LOVE
WITH JENNIFER LOPEZ,
AND THAT PICTURE
DOESN'T LOOK LIKE IT.
>> THE GUY BEHIND YOU LOOKS
LIKE HE'S IN LOVE WITH HER.
>> (laughs)
>> AND IT'S A SHAME,
BECAUSE YOU'VE GIVEN US
SOME FABULOUS PHOTOGRAPHS.
>> MICHELLE.
YOU WERE VERY STACCATO...
"DA-DA-DA-DA-DA...
AND THERE'S MR. JAY."
>> OH, IT'S TYRA!
>> AND THEN
THERE'S TYRA'S WEAVE.
>> (laughter)
>> LOVE IT.
>> IT JUST LOOKS LIKE LOVE.
MR. JAY SAID THAT
YOUR ELLEN DeGENERES
WAS "FRIGHTLINGLY"...
I CAN'T SAY THAT WORD.
>> FRIGHTENINGLY.
>> FRIGHT-EN-ING-LY.
(laughs)
HE SAID YOUR ELLEN DeGENERES
WAS REALLY GOOD.
>> AS ELLEN,
MICHELLE, YOU WERE GREAT.
>> LET'S SEE A CLOSE-UP
OF PORTIA.
YOUR EYES ARE CLOSED,
AND IT'S STILL PRETTY.
>> THANK YOU.
>> MELROSE.
I GOTTA SAY, YOU WERE CONFIDENT.
>> INVENTIVE, UPBEAT,
A LITTLE BIT OF FLAVOR.
HEY, YOU KNOW WHAT?
ONE OF THE BEST OF THE EVENING.
>> AND, MELROSE,
YOU WERE THE CHALLENGE WINNER.
>> YAY! I AGREE!
>> THEY HAD TO INTERVIEW
JANICE DICKINSON
ON THE RED CARPET.
>> OOH.
>> (laughter)
>> THAT'S ABSOLUTELY BRILLIANT!
>> (laughs)
>> NO, YOU GUYS HAVE NO IDEA.
THAT FRAME OF DONALD TRUMP--
THAT WAS HER FIRST FRAME.
>> IT WAS.
DO THE FACE NOW.
HOW WOULD YOU DO IT?
>> (laughter)
>> (imitates Donald Trump)
YOU'RE FIRED!
>> TO ME, MELANIA--
THERE'S SOMETHING ABOUT HER
THAT JUST FEELS REGAL,
AND I SEE THAT THERE.
ALL RIGHT,
LAST BUT NOT LEAST, ANCHAL.
YOU LOOK LIKE YOU WERE JUST
WALKING TO YOUR DEATH.
>> 'CAUSE I KNOW
MY COMMENTARY SUCKED.
>> I JUST WANTED
TO LOOK AWAY IN THE END.
IT WAS--IT WAS TOO--IT WAS TOO--
>> WE STARTED
TALKING ABOUT FOOD.
I HAVE TWO ROLE MODELS IN LIFE--
ONE IS MY MOTHER,
AND THE OTHER IS...
>> OPRAH.
>> THIS PICTURE
EMBODIES HER TO THE TEE--
THE ARM AND THE HAIR,
THE WHOLE THING.
STEDMAN OVER THERE--
WELL, I DON'T KNOW
IF THAT'S YOUR FAULT
OR IF THAT'S JUST BAD MAKEUP,
'CAUSE STEDMAN IS
A FINE, HANDSOME MAN.
BUT YOUR ENERGY IS REALLY GOOD.
LIKE, STEDMAN,
HE KIND OF POSES WITH HIS HEAD,
LIKE, TILTED UP.
BUT THAT HAIR AND MAKEUP--
I'M SORRY, WHOEVER DID THAT
SHOULD BE SHOT.
>> (laughs) OH!
>> HOW DID IT FEEL
TO PLAY OPRAH WINFREY,
SUCH A POWERFUL
AND INSPIRING WOMAN?
>> I TRIED, LIKE,
TRIED TO GET IN
ALL HER CONFIDENCE.
SHE SPENDS $1 MILLION A WEEK,
SHE FLIES TO GO GET DOUGHNUTS,
SO MIGHT AS WELL--
>> WAIT, SO OPRAH WINFREY,
ALL THE THINGS
THAT SHE'S DONE...
>> BUILDING A SCHOOL.
>> HURRICANE KATRINA
AND HELPING WOMEN AND--
>> YEAH, GOING ABOUT,
TRYING TO GET DOUGHNUTS.
>> (laughs)
>> I DIDN'T SAY IT, OPRAH.
SHE DID.
>> ALL RIGHT, SO NOW IT'S TIME
FOR THE JUDGES TO DELIBERATE,
AND WHEN I CALL YOU BACK,
I WILL ANNOUNCE WHICH ONE OF YOU
WILL BE ELIMINATED.
>> ALL RIGHT,
SO WE HAVE TO DECIDE
WHICH ONE OF THESE
SWEET LITTLE CHICKADEES
IS GOING HOME.
>> WELL, MELROSE HAS CERTAINLY
RISEN IN THE RANKS.
I CAN'T QUITE BELIEVE IT.
SHE DOESN'T SEEM LIKE A MODEL,
BUT SHE TURNS IT ON.
>> EUGENA.
I THINK JIGGA BABE IS COOL.
BEYONCé...
>> I CAN'T DO IT.
>> EUGENA...
JAEDA.
>> (imitates Whitney Houston)
BOBBY, I THINK THAT JAEDA
WOULD BE GREAT
IF SHE CAN JUST
PULL IT TOGETHER.
>> BUT THE CONFIDENCE IN JAEDA
JUST ISN'T THERE.
>> SHE WAS VERY UNHAPPY TODAY.
>> CARIDEE.
>> I THINK SHE'S EXTRAORDINARY.
>> DEFINITELY,
DEFINITELY A KEEPER.
I LOVE THIS GIRL.
>> BROOKE.
>> A STRONG PICTURE FOR BROOKE,
AND IT WAS A STRONG PERFORMANCE
BY BROOKE.
>> BROOKE GETS
TOP MARKS THIS WEEK.
>> A.J.--THIS IS
A GLAMOROUS PICTURE, AND I DON'T
THINK SHE WANTS TO DO GLAMOUR.
SHE WANTS TO DO DARK.
BUT AS A MODEL,
YOU HAVE TO DO EVERYTHING.
>> EVERYTHING.
>> BUT I THINK WITH A.J.--
>> BUT SHE CAN PHOTOGRAPH.
SHE'S DONE SOME GREAT SHOTS.
>> AMANDA.
>> I REALLY LIKE AMANDA.
I THINK SHE HAS POTENTIAL.
>> MICHELLE.
I FEEL LIKE I AM LOOKING
AT ELLEN DeGENERES.
SHE GOT IT.
>> BETWEEN AMANDA AND MICHELLE,
I PICK AMANDA.
>> AND YOU PICK?
>> I PICK MICHELLE.
>> THE PHOTOGRAPHERS
ARE FIGHTING.
(imitates bell) DING-DING!
ANCHAL.
>> WELL, THE PICTURE
OF HER AS OPRAH
IS--IS A LOVELY PHOTOGRAPH,
BUT SHE JUST IS SO INSECURE.
>> BUT ANCHAL IS SO POWERFUL
IN THE MEDIA.
HOW COULD HAVE YOU POSSIBLY
GIVEN UP ON HER?
>> (laughs)
>> 'CAUSE SHE FLIES
FOR DOUGHNUTS!
>> OH, CHILD,
THE PLANE JUST CAME IN.
>> AND THEY SAY
MODELS DON'T EAT.
>> O! OPRAH.
>> WE LOVE YOU, O.
>> THANK YOU, OPRAH!
♪♪
>> NINE GIRLS STAND BEFORE ME,
BUT I ONLY HAVE EIGHT PHOTOS
IN MY HANDS,
AND THESE PHOTOS REPRESENT
THE EIGHT GIRLS THAT WILL
STILL BE IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE FIRST NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL IS...
BROOKE.
>> OH, MY GOODNESS!
>> CONGRATULATIONS, BROOKE.
YOU SO ROCKED THAT JUDGING TEST
AND THIS PHOTO.
>> THANK YOU, GUYS.
>> MELROSE.
>> (laughs)
>> CONGRATULATIONS, MELROSE.
AMANDA.
CARIDEE.
>> OH!
>> MICHELLE.
>> YOU DIDN'T EVEN HAVE TO SAY
MY NAME.
>> YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> THANKS.
>> EUGENA.
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU.
>> (imitates Oprah Winfrey)
ANCHAL!
>> THANK YOU.
OH, MY GOSH,
YOU GAVE ME A HEART ATTACK.
THANK YOU.
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU.
>> WILL JAEDA AND A.J.
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
>> HMM.
>> I HAVE ONE PHOTO IN MY HANDS,
AND THIS PHOTO REPRESENTS
THE GIRL THAT IS STILL
IN THE RUNNING TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
I WILL ONLY CALL ONE NAME,
AND THE GIRL THAT I DO NOT CALL
MUST IMMEDIATELY
RETURN TO THE HOUSE,
PACK HER BELONGINGS
AND GO HOME.
BOTH OF YOU ARE STANDING BEFORE ME
BECAUSE THE JUDGES AREN'T SURE
HOW MUCH YOU CARE.
A.J., YOU TAKE ABSOLUTELY
BEAUTIFUL PICTURES.
ALL OF THESE GIRLS OVER HERE...
THE JUDGES FEEL A DESIRE
INSIDE OF THEM,
AND BEING A MODEL IS MORE
THAN JUST LOOKING LIKE ONE.
IT'S ABOUT WANTING
TO BE ONE, TOO.
JAEDA, YOUR PICTURES
HAVEN'T BEEN SO STRONG,
SO WHAT YOU NEED IS A LEVEL
OF CONFIDENCE AND CARING
THAT IS SO STRONG
THAT IT OVERSHADOWS
THOSE WEAK PICTURES.
BUT YOU CAME IN HERE TODAY
SO DEFEATED
AND ALMOST ABOVE THE TEST
THAT WE HAD YOU DO.
THIS COMPETITION
IS ABOUT TRYING.
IS ABOUT PASSION,
AND BOTH OF YOU ALL LACK THAT.
BOBBY BROWN
SAVED YOUR BUTT, JAEDA.
WE SAW PASSION
IN HALF OF THIS PHOTO,
SOMETHING SO STRONG
THAT WE HAVE NOT SEEN
FOR THIS ENTIRE COMPETITION.
NOW IT'S TIME TO SELL YOU.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> THANK YOU.
>> (whispers) THANK YOU, A.J.
IT'S COOL, GUYS.
MELROSE, YOU HAVE IT.
YOU SHOULD BE NICE, OKAY?
>> THANKS.
>> I THINK TYRA ELIMINATED ME
FOR THE RIGHT REASONS.
IF I COULD GIVE UP MY SPOT
FOR ANOTHER GIRL
WHO IS MORE DESERVING,
THEN I'M REALLY GLAD
I GAVE IT UP.
I THINK IT'S DEFINITELY POSSIBLE
THAT, YOU KNOW,
I COULD'VE SABOTAGED MYSELF
SUBCONSCIOUSLY.
YOU KNOW, WHAT COULD'VE BEEN,
COULD'VE BEEN. WHATEVER.
I'M NOT GONNA THINK ABOUT IT,
BECAUSE... IT'S DONE.
♪♪